history is filled with powerful states
defeating their weaker neighbors yet in
1848 in order to secure these
territories the German Confederation
excluding Austria led by the rising
Prussia sought to defeat Denmark it did
not and given the size and power
difference between the two entities this
raises a pretty obvious question how how
did Denmark defeat Prussia and its
German allies so as of 1848 Europe was a
bit of a mess revolutions had spread
across the continent and nationalist
sentiment was on the rise Denmark was
not EX from this and those living in the
South were filled with nationalist
fervor German fervor that was since they
weren't Danes and no longer wish to be a
part of Denmark fortunately for them it
looked like this was going to happen in
due course because the current king of
Denmark Frederick iith didn't have any
hirs this meant that after Frederick
died the duchies of slesvig and Holstein
and the Kingdom of Denmark would go to
different rulers due to different rules
of succession as the Revolution spread
across Europe there was a rumor that the
king of Denmark had been overthrown in
Copenhagen and so in sches fig and
Holstein their leaders declared the
creation of a a provisional government
this government wanted to make its own
laws and for sches to join the German
Confederation the duchies were the
richest part of Denmark and thus the
king could never let them go and so War
the German Confederation wanted to keep
Denmark out of what it saw as German
business and so it asked Prussia to
protect the duchies which it did sending
troops North the prussians clashed with
the Danish and their forces soon
Advanced to here at this point the rest
of Europe started to panic because it
looked like Prussia was on the verge of
conquering Denmark this was a problem
because Denmark controlled access to the
Baltic Sea Denmark wasn't able to close
the Straits to one great power without
the help of another however Prussia
theoretically could which for Britain
Sweden Norway and Russia was a problem
the British offered to mediate and send
the fleet to intimidate Prussia but the
Danish said no the Swedish sent troops
to hear as a warning and Russia
threatened allout War if Russia tried to
seize all of Denmark now Prussia didn't
want to fight a major war and so it
agreed to a ceasefire in order to
negotiate the problem was that the rest
of the German Confederation did not and
in 1849 sches Holstein continued the War
without Prussian troops although there
were Prussian volunteers and its
commander-in-chief was a Prussian too
Denmark was able to hold its own at this
point and so its negotiating position
was Stronger which is why it refused to
agree to any changes the prussians were
still very aware that if they got
involved again it would spark a major
war unless they could find allies their
natural first choice would be Austria
but given that the Russians had just
helped the hapsburgs crush a Hungarian
Uprising they were in their depth
furthermore the German Confederation was
undergoing a lot of changes itself and
Prussia had championed major changes
which under Austria's position there
these were so bad that Austrian
leadership were considering invading
Prussia to put an end to them so
obviously they weren't interested this
left France president Louie Napoleon who
was just a president and wasn't planning
on anything more it's weird that you
even brought it up hinted at potentially
helping if there were territorial
concessions for France along the rine
this was obviously a no no because
Prussia saw itself as the leader of the
German World and selling some of those
Germans to a foreign power to gain some
more wasn't going to happen thus Prussia
understood that it had no future in the
war which is why it pressured the rest
of the German Confederation to admit
defeat which they did as a result of
negotiations Hol steam was briefly
occupied by Austrian and Prussian troops
in order to ease it being handed back to
Denmark which was completed in 1852 and
with that Denmark was Victorious not
through a military victory over Prussia
but a diplomatic one with the help of
the rest of Europe's great Powers I hope
you enjoyed this episode with a special
thanks to my patrons James Bizet Kelly
moneymaker K show wolf Sky Chappelle
kitka Anthony Becket rod Martin Udan
Wang Marcus arner Y and hockey Alex
Schwin AF Firefly Captain side dog
Spencer Lightfoot Gustav Swan the MC
Whopper shenin Marvin CAU Winston kward
spinning three plates Andy McGee kimun
Yun calling Dr Howard Dr Fine Dr Howard
Todd short copper tone Maggie patkowski
words about books podcast Jim Stromberg
Miss iset and Charles
I